il était une icône du sport il a été
condamné pour le meurtre de sa compagne
voici l'histoire de l'athlète
paralympique
Oscar Pistorius en cette histoire a été
énorme mais en plus le scénario était
non
thriller
de ce drame cette savoir s'il savait
qu'il tirait sur sa compagne ou pas
nous sommes le 14 février 2013 jour de
la Saint-Valentin dans un quartier huppé
et ultra sécurisé de Pretoria en Afrique
du Sud aux alentours de 3h du matin le
champion d'athlétisme
Oscar Pistorius appelle ses voisins pour
leur demander de l'aide
sa version des faits immédiate c'est de
dire que il était sorti sur le balcon de
sa chambre pour aller chercher un
ventilateur parce que là une fois sur le
balcon il a entendu du bruit venant de
la salle de bain armée de son pistolet
Parabellum
Oscar Pistorius se dirige vers la salle
de bain et tire à quatre reprises à
travers la porte des toilettes
à l'intérieur sa petite amie rivastine
camp est touchée à la hanche au bras et
à la tête
[Musique]
Sony
je me souviens très bien du 14 février
2013 d'autant que le journal m'a
rapidement appelé pour me demander si je
pouvais me rendre en Afrique du Sud très
vite l'athlète est arrêtée puis déféré
devant un juge qui doit évaluer s'il
peut être libéré dans l'attente de son
procès l'audience est retransmise en
direct et diffusé par les télévisions du
monde entier là c'est une folie absolue
ça bipède partout plus personne ne
pouvait gérer le flot de des
journalistes
féminisée mais nous on l'adore Oscar
mais là c'est pas possible il s'est
attaqué à une femme
je vais rencontrer Pistorius au tout
début quand il a été autorisé à courir
parmi les valides
c'était quelqu'un qui était très très
avenant super souriant et c'était une
énorme attraction pour le pour le milieu
de l'athlétisme
Oscar Pistorius est né en 1986 à
Johannesburg avec une malformation aux
jambes ses parents décident de le faire
amputer à 11 mois et le jeune Oscar
apprend rapidement à se déplacer à
l'aide de prothèses il y avait une
phrase célèbre de sa maman qui quand
elle l'appelait lui et son frère elle
disait Carl mettait chaussures
Oscar met tes jambes on sort ça on
disait beaucoup parce qu'il a été élevé
comme comme quelqu'un qui n'aurait pas
été un handicapé du tout et dans son
esprit je pense qu'il y a bien des
égards il ne se considérait pas comme
handicapé à l'adolescence
Oscar Pistorius pratique plusieurs
sports mais à la suite d'une blessure
contractée au rugby il se met à
l'athlétisme et en 2004 il participe aux
Jeux paralympiques d'Athènes à seulement
17 ans
il gagne des médailles mais ça ne touche
pas encore le grand public quoi
ce qui va vraiment faire entrer
Pistorius dans la notoriété c'est quand
il va obtenir le droit de courir parmi
les valides en 2007 puis pour lui c'est
une logique c'est l'étape d'après il
veut pas se contenter du sport
paralympique les ambitions de Scar
Pistorius intriguent les médias et
bouscule le monde du sport il gagne
rapidement le surnom de Blade Runner
mais est-il oui ou non avantagé par ses
prothèses la question fait débat et la
Fédération internationale d'athlétisme
en s'appuyant sur une étude scientifique
lui interdit de participer aux Jeux
Olympiques de 2012 avec les athlètes
valides
il finit par obtenir gain de cause
devant le Tribunal Arbitral du Sport et
il est autorisé à participer aux Jeux
Olympiques parmi les valides
Oscar Pistorius est alors au sommet de
sa gloire
[Musique]
le coureur au lames je me souviens de
Bolt passant à côté comme inintéressait
personne comparativement quoi il était
le phénomène médiatique du moment il
était aussi un phénomène économique ça
renommée dépasse désormais le cadre du
sport
Oscar Pistorius est invité dans les LED
show américain participe à plusieurs
émissions télé et enchaînent les
contrats publicitaires le contrat qu'il
a avec Nike par exemple est l'un des
l'un des plus gros peut-être même le
plus gros en athlétisme vous avez fait
une campagne d'ailleurs qui était assez
terrible ils ont pas eu le temps d'en
sortir mais c'était une campagne où on
le voyait partant comme dans une
position de starting block avec je suis
la balle dans le barillet
nous sommes à la fin de l'année 2012
quelques mois seulement après les Jeux
Olympiques de Londres
Oscar Pistorius est à l'apogée de sa
carrière et depuis quelques semaines il
s'affiche avec la mannequin rivastine
camp avec qui il semble filer le parfait
amour
[Musique]
c'était très récentes Pistorius et
c'était une campe ne se rend compte que
trois mois avant le drame elle est
plutôt en fin de carrière de mannequinat
et elle se reconvertit plutôt vers la
télé elle est assez brillante elle a
fait des études de droit et donc elle
vient de tourner une émission qui était
appelée à être diffusée plus tard
le drame c'est qu'il est un peu pressé
elle sent quand même en lui parfois des
excès
[Musique]
quelque temps après avoir été inculpé
pour le meurtre de revasting camp
l'image d'Oscar Pistorius ce dernier un
peu plus alors qu'une histoire de
violence à l'encontre d'une femme refait
surface
[Musique]
Oscar Pistorius et dépeint dans les
médias et par le procureur comme une
personne jalouse impulsive et colérique
il est excessif d'ailleurs jusqu'à sans
prendre au nouveau petit ami de ses ex
en les pourrissant en leur disant que il
allait leur péter les jambes à l'un
d'entre eux
il a un amour pour les armes à feu
vraiment énorme donc il y a eu des choix
tirés à travers le toit ouvrant d'une
voiture
sous son lit ou sous son oreiller
[Musique]
qui tourne mal ils sont convaincus que
Pistorius va à la salle de bain ou se
réfugier il va se tenkamp parce qu'ils
se sont engueulés et qu'il tirent à
travers la porte parce qu'il est furieux
dès le début ils estiment que c'est un
crime avec préméditation quoi donc c'est
un assassinat
à l'issue du procès le parquet n'a pas
pu prouver l'après méditation
Oscar Pistorius et finalement reconnu
coupable d'homicide involontaire et
condamné à 5 ans de prison
l'accusation n'a jamais réussi à
démontrer vraiment qui avait eu une
engueulade entre avant il a été
finalement démontré après les analyses
balistiques qu'il était bien sur ses
moignons quand il a tiré à travers la
porte et non pas qu'il aurait pris le
temps de mettre ses prothèses il y a un
certain nombre de choses comme ça la
vessie de Riva était quasiment vide donc
effectivement elle a pu aller aux
toilettes quand pendant que lui il était
il était sur sur son balcon
peu de temps après la condamnation la
Cour suprême sud-africaine demande la
requalification des faits en meurtre la
juge doit prononcer un nouveau verdict
au lieu de lui donner 5 ans elle lui
donne 6 ans juste une année de plus
alors que dans la loi sud-africaine un
crime c'est 15 ans en gros il y a c'est
pas écrit comme ça dans les textes mais
ça se passe toujours comme ça
insatisfait du nouveau verdict le
parquet fait appel et en 2017
Oscar Pistorius et Coop cette fois-ci de
13 ans et 5 mois de prison
en mars 2023 alors qu'il est en mesure
de bénéficier d'une libération
conditionnelle celle-ci lui est refusée
la réalité c'est que dans cette histoire
il n'y a qu'un seul témoin et que c'est
Oscar Pistorius disant après on ne sait
toujours pas on saura peut-être jamais